now thirsting let's have a go you can
see they begin right away by saying show
that be that expression for how many
bacteria there are at a certain number
of T hours sure that it satisfies the
differential equation do peyote blow a
lot so again just like I did here the
best way is just take this thing and
differentiate and show it satisfies
right so let's just go ahead and do that
if this is what I think B is what's DPO
DT again right that constant coefficient
up folks it doesn't affect my
differentiation they go ahead and
differentiate this guy done okay and you
can see here all I need to do is make
the B part of the expression more
obvious just sort of highlight it there
and you like look that's the zero point
one where I think they have it in the
form they've got a factor okay so
there's the differential equation yeah
just let me point out like I mentioned
before this key number right this guy up
here so I start again this guy tells you
where you begin your first value and
this guy tells you how quickly you grow
or how quickly you decay
okay for that reason that schmuck it
spits out here for a second because this
is confusing because this is about where
you start initial condition and how fast
I just defined the speed of everything
this number K is often called the growth
rate now that is intensely confusing
because even though it's true
it defines how quickly everything
happens in our language of rates of
change we would actually not call K the
growth rate usually what would we call
the growth rate in this situation did BL
DT it's how the battery population is
changing over time okay now really
carefully when you're looking through a
question they will make clear which one
is which but you just need to know that
both of these are often called I'm sort
of connected to this idea of the rent
okay
the K number it does change whether this
happens faster weather happens slow okay
generally the way that if they want you
to work out this one rather than that
one
they might often say instantaneous
growth rate
at a particular instant in time deep
unity is whatever that's that's what
calculus is for whether whereas this
number this is constant this is always
the same for a whole model for a whole
population
generally speaking you also have a look
at the question and if there are
multiple parts and if one asks for
growth rate and then number asks for
add a particular at the time where T
equals none another what is the growth
rate then clearly they don't need this
one because this is who cares what time
it is for that is always the same number
so look carefully at the weight any
question it will give you clues okay all
right puppy it says initially the number
batch here is estimated to be thousand
five how many bacteria there are
laughter three hours okay so all we need
to do at this point is to say well B
naught is the initial condition right so
I'm going to say B equals a thousand
times this okay I also know T so I'm
just gonna lay that their first there
because I'm gonna use this equation
later on now that I've got the equation
for B and now I could say when T equals
it's three hours right 300 okay when T
equals 3 B is equal to a thousand each
other and I like to do my straight
substitution before I actually plug into
my calculator a thousand each about 0.3
so I'm gonna write my as usual I'm going
to write my calculator readout and then
I'm gonna make my approximation
okay so we raised this question of like
if we think about this this Court is
ready right and we think oh and such a
time like I don't know someone come help
me out with biology there's some
bacteria and it's currently in the
process of splitting what's that go
mitosis meiosis
what's it okay so it's in the process
I'm always there but clearly I have not
actually slipped just yet so there is an
argument when it has to do with
populations you can say well I've not
had the 1350s yet so therefore I really
ought to always round down this is a
similar kind of argument to what we're
looking at series the sequences you have
to pay something off and we said this is
how many dollars you have everyone
well you can't round that down because
then when you get to the end you'll
still have some about oh right so you
have to always round out oh now here's
what I'm going to say there's something
in the question that tells you even
though that's a valid line of argument
there's not really much point going to
that level of detail and you should just
round to the nearest number have a look
again at the question it says initially
that number of bacteria is what it's
estimated right so that thing already
has some kind of rounding built into it
right so it's not like I am watching it
up like yeah thousand one thousand two
thousand and three right we don't have
that level of detail so we're not like
oh look I'm pointing up 85 percent so
that next bacteria no no no just go to
the nearest mile and that's why they
helpfully say just answer correct to the
nearest that's the other clue just
asking for you to round okay so don't
worry too much I'm making a detailed
argument that pretty much pretty much
okay because again remember I said and
this is it is a there's a joke about
physicists which is that you know you're
thinking about something and it's like
assume assume that this situation is
like a perfectly spherical object with
no friction and blah blah blah blah and
that's the only way you can use an
idealized situation like this because we
know in reality there are far more
variables involved the just tired so
this is just a model it's just
model and so that's why you can always
pretty much do something like these
because they're really other factors
that complicated okay
right let's have a look but see you use
Parts A and B to find out I can't you
see how there's a clue in here right
find how fast the number of bacteria is
growing after three hours so you see
they specify a time that's what tells
you hey I want DPM DB or DT right that's
the thing I'm after because if you
wanted at a particular time then it
doesn't matter where when you are if
you're after this really bad is when you
are if you're after this okay so let's
have a look at this I already have right
from the first line I've already got my
expression for DP DT right so when sigh
this is Part C when T equals three right
I already established that DB of T is
just simply this DV DT equals 1/10 of
whatever the population is right now the
second which I just worked out was 1350
it will calculus required
it won't substitution back into this
differential equation all right that's
the whole point of exponential growth in
decay to say if you know how big the
population is then you should be able to
know what girls brain you've got roughly
so that's that's approximately a hundred
and thirty-five hundred thirty-five what
battery per hour right because the units
bacteria and the time is power
I'm not used to measuring things in
bacteria per hour how far you go I hope
that hundred they buy back to your car
okay last one by solving and then they
give you these equations I'll just look
at the equation for a second what does
this equation represent yeah they're so
soon be 10,000 will be right so that's
why you can use that equation to find
correct to the nearest hour where V when
the population will be 10,000 bacteria
okay so so you can imagine by the way
this is the first question so often we
will not get handed this you'll just
have to generate this equation and
substitute in B equals 10,000 or because
whatever so let's write this down equals
1 after a value for T t so I'm gonna
have to evaluate it's not started what
does it oh sorry
I want to get to
when is my population going to decouple
okay gets it 10 times bigger so you can
see by the way that's important because
when you cancel here you just end up
with 10 right so your initial population
if you wanted to go through same double
right and even if you didn't know what
your initial population was you could
still want that out right because you'd
have P naught here and then you'd have 2
times P naught you don't even know what
to D work out with the initial
population lines so here I've got a to
the 0 1 T equals 10 so now I will take
more looks at both sides or I'll just
rewrite this
as a long crazy uncle zero poll of t
equals log 10 yeah so teak wasn't gonna
multiply both sides by 10 I guess 10 log
10 some 1.02 they went to the nearest
outlet again because this whole model is
approximated so therefore I'm just gonna
say 23 after 23 hours okay now just
before we leave off this question that
first line of Oh tell me when we're
gonna get to 10,000 bacteria right if I
wanted to know like suppose I now start
with 10,000 bacteria like this is my new
stop point how long will it take me to
get to a hundred thousand bacteria to
again me ten times as much and the
answer is because if I just change those
two numbers at the top to be initially
10,000 and eventually 100,000 what will
be different about the subsequent
working answer nothing will be different
in my subsequent working right because
I'm still going to kids allowed zeros
I'm just gonna cancel out more often and
I still had not returned on the right
hand side right that's that how much
bigger the population is so in other
words it took me 23 hours took me a day
to get from a thousand to a hundred
thousand but hourly sorry a thousand to
ten thousand but it only takes me
another day to get from 10,000 to
100,000 and another day to get from
100,000 to a million right and that's
the whole idea of exponential growth the
big year are the faster you could grow